you've got three options when it comes
to buying a next-generation console or
is it Kurt generation the ps4 is a great
one it's even got an online service that
offers more than just access to
multiplayer instant game collection
gives you a host of great games as part
of PlayStation Plus and with sales
already reaching 4.2 million units
you'll find plenty of friends to play
with online too but those are the only
reasons you should buy a ps4 in 2014
the ps4's the lineup of games might be a
little sparse as a press time but
they're still plenty to keep you
entertained on the exclusive side
there's Killzone Shadowfall which for
all its faults is an impressive showcase
of the ps4 power and it offers up to
mighty fine multiplayer then there's
knack actually the less said about knack
the better
then there's the ps4 as many indie
titles the best of which is resogun an
old-school shoot them up dressed in some
very pretty voxels also worth checking
out are the excellent flower and sound
shapes of course there's all the usual
cross-platform stuff to dig into - with
the likes of Assassin's Creed 4 FIFA 14
and Call of Duty ghosts they feature
noticeable graphical improvements over
their last gen versions and let's not
forget that the ps4 has been topping the
Xbox one's visuals most famously of all
with caught ghosts a game that runs
natively at 1080p on Sony's machine and
at an upscaled 720p on Microsoft's it's
also what's coming up in 2014 that makes
ps4 a worthy Buy and there are some
great-looking exclusives on the way
sucker-punches infamous second son is
looking tasty
don't forget about driveclub shadow of
the beast and the order 1886 all on the
way not to mention whatever Naughty Dog
has in store for Uncharted 4
Sony's love of indie developers has
landed it some great-looking timed
exclusives - with the stunning looking
adventure rhyme and the wonderfully
intense hotline Miami - wrong number
both making their console debut on ps4
mark and I are both particularly excited
for the witness a misc like take on the
puzzle game created by Jonathan Blow the
man behind the brilliant braid you'll
also be set for all the cross-platform
games like watchdogs Tom Clancy's the
division Mad Max and destiny the ps4 has
a sleek monolithic vibe about it that
just screams cool it might not be as
cheap as a Wii U but the ps4 is
certainly cheaper than an Xbox one even
if you weren't a fan of Sony's DualShock
3 controller it's worth checking out the
dual shop for
thank the improvement to its grips
analog sticks and size make it a far
better pad than its predecessor the ps4
gives you access to apps like Netflix
and Hulu without having to subscribe to
PlayStation Plus you can also stream
straight to twitch and Ustream with just
the push of a button Vita owners can
make use of remote play too which lets
you stream ps4 games straight to your
handheld a ps4 it sure is a next-gen
machine with a thoughtful UI and a
lineup of great games right now but it's
what's coming up that makes it so
enticing so what is it that awaits you
in 2014
well only if you buy a ps4 though right
right